hi I'm Lilly James and welcome to my
glamour shoot
today what I was wearing is much more on
keeping with how I would normally dress
em I had dungarees off-the-shoulder
dresses and I bought quite a long neck
huh too long
each photo had a sort of its own
soundtrack in a different vibe and and
it was them there was sort of a
character and a sort of story in each
photo which which make means I really
really enjoy it and one big fluffy
Barker's I made a burr desk dress and
then I was jumping around and I think
David said pretender in the sea and so I
was actually I kind of felt like I was
in a washing machine had a really fun
day of shooting Lily James for our big
fashion March issue cover shoot I'm
starting with something like this which
is this cute little zip up silk jacket
but it actually has this open back and
really amazing ruffles along the edges
and slight ruffle color we loved this
sort of one-shoulder top and by Markus
Almeida and putting it with the brown
leather and then we also went for the
dungarees referencing the 90s again but
sort of the strap falling off the
shoulder these are wrong long ribbon
details are quite key for next season as
well and then we've got all these sort
of full-on ruffles again it's quite over
the top but there's sort of a 90s
reference money through everything that
would gives it that more down-to-earth
feel I love the first look which was
this really cool brand of the jacket and
with this sort of like off the shoulder
falling off the top and I thought that
was really cool but I also the Chloe
dungarees
that's literally I would wear them every
day if I owned them